he told us guys if you wanna if you
wanna have one contract with the
government that would enable you to to
connect with all different
uh uh public transit operators it would
take years so instead of that
go straight forward to the to the
operations themselves
sign up contracts with them and then the
government would would adopt
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
today we're going to talk about
transportation in israel from the
payments perspective
meet of sinai the co-founder of hop-on
hop-on is the pioneer app for transit
payments in israel
it serves more than one million users a
month which use their services for
navigating and paying through their
commute on buses trains and big taxis
hop on today has presence in five
different countries which includes
russia
germany czech republic uk and israel it
was founded in 2013 by ophel sinai
while he was taking his daily commute
from petratikva towards kpmg office in
tel aviv
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
doing great thank you
great the co-founder of hop on
i'm excited to hear about the journey of
a
public transportation digital payments
in
in an old regulated industry but coming
and and digitalizing it with it with
investors from
all over the world including a
transportation companies within israel
but also from germany
and most recently a car importer
also i believe invested just over four
and a half million dollars and
and so a really exciting journey and i'm
excited to pick your brain about
you know really what what is hop on and
take me back you know even
almost 10 years ago to the founding of
it and and what was sort of you know
going through your mind back then
all right so it wasn't 10 years ago it
was 2013.
uh so back then i was i was actually
working at the local kpmg firm
and uh tel aviv offices and the city
center and i used to live in the
petra and i i was actually doing
my my daily uh my daily commute with
uh uh wood 51 of uh dan company the bus
operator of tel aviv
and it took me about an year uh to
travel the
uh to travel route 51 on the database
and i realized the bus is spending too
much time at bus stops
uh that means during rush hours instead
of just you know
fighting against the the traffic uh the
bus is actually
stopping at bus stop for too much time
and too much time means that
back then it can take up to four minutes
per station
uh just to accept people and allow
people to step in and pay their rights
and
and this is this is one example of of
thing that you know
it was sitting in my mind every day
while i was commuting i was
measuring how much time it takes i you
know
the bus to to to get out from the bus
stop
and what and and what uh throw me into
the
into the public transit market uh
eventually was uh
uh one time that i was actually uh uh
hopping on the bus
uh together with uh with my friend uh we
didn't have
any cash so we were actually staying the
the driver zoe we
we are out of cash uh is it something
else we can do
and then my friend uh um
he told me oh listen i have a two dollar
bill
uh like i have dollar bills uh because
he was renting apartments in tel aviv
back then
uh for tourists so we always have us
dollars but never
shekels so we just say all right so
let's pay with dollars so we asked the
driver are you is it okay for us to pay
with you us dollars
so yeah why why not and we realized
immediately what's happening here okay
this is a
very old-fashioned market that was stuck
i don't know somewhere in the uh
uh in the middle of a last century and
we realized that something has to be
changed because you know
if if this is how money is being
transferred from
passengers users to the bus driver
definitely something is wrong and that
was the you know the the slap that
actually throw us into
the market and we start to to learn the
the industry
uh and to understand who are the players
and what we can actually
uh build and offer in order to improve
and and to digitize the
the the payment in the in the in the
low in our local uh bus uh uh
uh bus market and
so we we actually we uh we schedule up a
meeting with the
guy who was uh the cfo of that company
same company done
and we actually told him the the same
story that what happened for us
and he realized that something is
definitely wrong
and we offer them all right so we we're
gonna put an app that would
enable people to to use their mobile
phones and pay the bus ride it sounds
very simple
but it wasn't there so we actually had
to invent it and
build it and i took some time
uh lucky for us today uh we in
just in tel aviv or in actually entire
gosh dan
we are facing almost 1 million
passengers per month
using our services to to pay the the
local uh
uh public transit network uh which is
amazing because you know
uh and using our technology we actually
enabled
the the public transit operators not
just in tel aviv but all through the
country
uh to to avoid getting cash on board
so i i don't know if you're familiar
with that but today when you go on board
into all of the buses in the country not
just in tel aviv
you're not able to pay the uh the driver
by cash anymore
and this is only because that there was
a technology that can actually be
an alternative for those old-fashioned
cash transactions
on board and so
this is it now take me back i guess
eight years and
you're with your friend and you're
you're observing these inefficiencies of
the bus and and you were
going back to that exact point where
you're watching
you know the bus is stopping for too
long what do you understand about
you know the reason why the bus is
stopping how do you arrive at the end of
the conclusion
that you know by digitalizing the
payment system you're actually going to
be able to solve
many of the issues that you are facing
personally in your own commute
yeah so so my my break one is actually a
financial one
so immediately what i was actually doing
when i was measuring how much time is
being spent
per per each bus stop i was just putting
all the data in
in an excel file and i was just you know
trying to figure out what are the
numbers what are the cost how much it
cost
that company uh again that done company
which has
1500 buses thousands of drivers
spending millions of shekels every month
on uh
on you know on the gas and fuel how much
that
cost them to to when when the bus stays
four minutes in that bus in each bus
stop during rush hours
and i was amazed okay we are talking
about millions of shekels
each month that are being spent just to
allow people to step in and step
out and and just pay the right
um so and this is right
the reason we went to meet with the cfo
we didn't meant to me
we didn't want to meet with any anyone
else from the company we want to meet
with the cfo
in order to show him you you're it's not
just
uh that you are old-fashioned you are
actually losing money because you are
old-fashioned
and uh and he was okay
he was convinced immediately you know
later on he became a partner he became a
shareholder when we started the company
uh because we met them we just had an
idea okay
so he told us guys go ahead let's go
build the company build the product
and and let's do it and he said in the
same
on the same meeting he said i want to be
one of your shareholders because i think
what you are doing
and solving up uh my issue can help
other companies as well
uh right and i believe that don done
today is one of the one of the biggest
shareholders of hop on right
and so it's a in obviously that's a huge
vote of confidence
share with me a little bit you know it's
exciting to talk about
old industries getting getting this
renovation
and getting this you know this digital
revolution i remember
no paying cash at you know on buses it's
been
you know forever it's been like this
obviously and until recently it was also
like this
and so you're actually changing a very
big shift in consumer behavior and i'm
guessing that it's not just a simple
you know okay yeah let's do it let's
change the whole system here in israel
what were some of the challenges that
you faced even regulatory-wise
that as you as you were building this
product was done all right so so of
course uh
the public transit industry in israel is
very regulated okay
all all different public transit
operators and there are more than 10
different private companies who are
actually operating the mass transit
network
for the government for the mlt ministry
of transportation
and they are all regulated by by
uh the mot and they cannot adopt
any change into the payment system
without getting the approval
uh from the mlt so it's not just
convincing
the client we have to also convince the
regulator that
it is also good for him because once
there are less cash transactions on
board there is less fraud
uh vehicles are moving faster and and
eventually people are getting
faster into their destination
um so you know we we met lucky for us we
found the right guy at the mlt
uh offices back then which was a
visionary like us
and he told us guys you know what
you got my approval okay and but you
don't really
need my approval value you have to go
through all the public transit operators
and convince them and you need to have
my support from the back
okay because if if you want to have a
contract with me as a government it
would take years
so go after the market go to the uh
transit operator in your case
convince them sign up contracts with
them and we will give them the support
that they need in order to
uh move move further with you and this
is exactly what we did
and he was right because some like
six or seven years after that
the government decided okay i want to
regulate the new
payment of the new market of the payment
for the public transit
and there was a big tender uh uh
back in 2019 that the government had
published and lucky for us we wanted
tender as well
and now we have the contract with the
government to run
public transit payments all over the
country but again
wow he was right he took the government
almost yeah some like eight years okay
uh since we uh we even met that guy he
was positive he wasn't negative at all
he was positive but he told us guys if
you wanna
if you wanna have one contract with the
government that would enable you to to
connect with all different
uh uh public transit operators it would
take years so instead of that
go straight forward to the to the
operations themselves sign up contracts
with them
and then the government would would
adopt so that was
the model that worked for us um
yeah so now that now that
it's everywhere basically and and you
know it's successful and
you're seeing the results what what's
what what's changed in the behavior of
the of the consumers of the buses
anything surprising or or things that
you expected and actually did happen
so first of all i'm happy to say bosses
are it's not us
saying it's you know people who are uh
investigating the market can definitely
say that
over the past years bosses are moving
even faster than
they used to used to move okay and the
main here
the main thing that or the main element
here that was changed
is the amount of time that those buses
are spending at the bus stops
okay even though the traffic is getting
worse from a day to day
uh in definitely in a city center
uh but buses are spending less time at
bus stop
and eventually people are getting faster
into their destinations which is a very
very good result
and on the other hand there is less
fraud okay
uh once you take away the cash and you
take away the
uh you know the uh the involvement of
the driver himself
uh so first of all less fraud and
secondly
very very important um more secured
and and a safe ride uh i don't know if
you remember a couple of years ago there
was a very big accident uh
on on one of the uh public transit buses
uh and and one of the outcomes was
that the drivers are just were used to
deal with so many things during their
the ride and during while they were
driving
and and again today if you're a bus
driver
you don't you don't deal with anything
else you just you just drive
i remember years riding the bus as being
amazed at
how how the bus drivers are
simultaneously
you know stopping the bus connecting
payments old
giving change doing everything with one
hand looking in one direction looking at
the street you know riding in a lane
with with
bikes and other cars in the same lane
stopping every two seconds
talking to the person in the back that
wants to get off it was
and i was thinking this this is crazy
this has to change so
so i'm really happy to hear that that it
is changing definitely
yeah and and you know what else we found
out that you know the
the public transit companies they're
it's really hard for them to
uh to get more drivers uh uh
to to to drive the buses uh it's really
it's uh
the demand here today uh according to
public transit operators
there in in the country they are missing
like
3 000 uh bus drivers okay but today when
they are putting uh
uh advertisement to to get more uh
uh drivers they are actually using that
element you don't have to deal with the
cash anymore
uh why don't you become a bus driver and
it's it's not just changing the life of
the passengers also
also changing the life of the bus
drivers that used to
be like a cashier and now they are just
driving
and then and it makes so so you what
you've actually done is
you're not just you know created a
win-win situation where you've created a
win-win-win-win situation
you know the obviously hop-on is
successful don is enjoying more
passengers more unique passengers and is
enjoying more money that is more
regulated
and doesn't have to count change the
drivers are having a better time and
consumers are much happier because they
don't have to carry change in their
pockets
especially as we enter a world where
everything is everything is completely
digital payments now
before we get to some more personal
questions about you you know tell me a
little bit about the decision
using barcodes and the way that you
integrated this and not traditionally
you know it could have they could have
implemented a simple swipe of a credit
card like in vending machines
or potentially you know with apple pay
so so why
why was your solution the one that that
makes most sense
all right so first of all uh uh we again
we are talking about
old-fashioned market okay not most of
the players here
they don't they don't want to invest
money so if you put in
another hardware into the bus that means
you have to pay
uh initial amount of money in order to
to integrate their hardware into the bus
and that would kill the project okay
because
once you come with and it doesn't matter
whether it's a couple of hundred
checkers or a thousand shekels
per bus it would kill the project so we
had to come with something which is
very very simple uh makes sense and
and you know also good for for the user
in terms of uh
user experience so
that was it uh on on most of don busses
alongside with the qrs we also equipped
the buses with beacons are you familiar
with beacons
so uh today all all of that buses has
beacons
and uh over the next few months we're
gonna
enable people uh to go on board
and instead of going to the qr and
scanning the qr
they'll be able just to open up the app
the app would recognize the beacon that
is there
amazing and would enable them to to
validate the ride and pay the ride
without having to go
and look or find the right qr
again if people doesn't want to give the
permission for bluetooth or etc so
they would still be able to scan those
qrs
well fair very very cool i love you know
the intersection of technology and how
we're
interacting with our day-to-day world
you know this is not another product
that people
you know you're creating a whole new
market for new people to go and buy
online you're changing the way people
are already interacting with their
physical world and i think that's just
awesome
and i have a few questions to you now as
the co-founder of hop on
going back all the way to middle school
or high school
what was your favorite subject what
fascinated you as a kid
um so since i came for a religious
school
okay you know and i'm not doing that
anymore
these days uh but talmud you know
yeah i i truly believe that you know
because i was uh i was learning when
when i was a kid i thought about it as a
okay why the hell the teacher and forced
me to learn
and why do i have to learn and why do i
have to know aramic which is a very old
language
nobody uses that anymore but i truly
believe
that it gave me a visionary uh
and it it gave me tools today that helps
me to solve problems or
once you know uh on the business side
you are dealing with many many problems
every day okay so you have to come with
the tools that would help you to solve
those problems along the way
and i truly believe that learning talmud
and kumara
definitely helped me today every day
uh even though i'm not learning too much
more today
but the background is there and the
knowledge is i hope it's still there
perfect and what about a source of
inspiration
somebody that inspires you a role model
of some sort
uh so i can i can say my father but if
we're
talking about uh someone that's not from
a family so that would be my uh
first commander in the army okay so i
was uh
i was in a cane and uh in a tank unit
back then uh and uh the commander of the
platoon uh
you know he was very strict uh
guy uh but you know
i was i was with him on a on few battles
okay we
we fought together back in gaza strip
and i'm talking about you
that was in 2004 and
i was amazed by him okay he was he was
inspiring and he you know it took me
here to say
okay i was actually admiring this guy
very very very cool and what are three
words that
you would use to describe yourself um
so it's kind of easy for me today i'm
actually
a mobility geek okay uh yeah
so that means i love mobility and it
doesn't matter
whether these are new electric vehicles
or scooters or
car sharing or whatever i'm i'm
definitely a mobility geek
i'm trying to you know to adopt whatever
i can and
and also uh because again we are
i'm we are facing almost one million uh
passengers every month wow trying to
make their mobility and their commute
even better
and amazing
very very very cool of i really want to
thank you for being here with me this
was wonderful and very insightful and i
and i really enjoyed uh getting it you
know a peek
into a transformation that is happening
in the
transportation space so thank you for
that and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
thank you cheers bye bye